The door shutters also got to the end first.
We'll have all the ends just once we get there.
Oh, just looking around probably.
It's not what we do on this deck.
We'll have all the ends just once we get there.
We'll start.
Don't forget to roll your was with the manage.
Can I choose only to get it?
Okay.
We took a long break, right?
I'm not sure if I can get it.
Bob has one.
Yeah.
I did want it longer.
That's why.
Wait.
Yeah, that's better.
Did you say that's better?
No, I mean,
I don't know.
I did.
I rolled the 16th.
Why isn't it not there?
Oh, there is a bass for steps here.
I'm not sure if I can get it.
Does he look familiar at all?
That's an interesting thing to be doing on the island.
There's an influence.
Does he look familiar to any of us?
Alright.
Betsy's going to freak him the fuck out.
He's fishing and sees a giant ass crab just rolled up.
Five dudes high-bought.
He's trying to catch the big catch.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm going to be like, damn bro, you got a big ass hole.
How are you going to cook this thing?
Everyone just stay aware of the bone man fishing on a smoking island
with a smoking island behind him.
Not normal.
A bone man, I thought he said an old man.
Wait, smoke?
Does Bob see the smoke now since Baptist said it?
Or how far are we from the island like less than 100?
I think I'm going to send Malin and try to see from his eyes
and see what's going on and why is the fire there?
[silence]
Oh by the way, I'm looking at Malin's eyes as long as we're not getting off.
Hey, Muffins.
Yeah.
Are we going to see Zapto soon?
I ain't going to lie to you, a pretty bird.
Can I call you Paulie?
What?
You're pretty bird.
[silence]
I'm just waiting until we get close to the island so we can do the man's reaction.
Oh, is the man not reacting?
Oh, I'll hop on.
And start walking towards.
100%.
I'm going to scare this shit out of him.
I'm going to roll, dude.
Look at your catch.
I'm just walking towards.
Yeah.
If Roma scares him into the freaking water.
That's the goal.
I'm jumping down and I'm running up and sneaky up to him.
And I'm just going to be at the top of my lungs.
Oh, look at your fucking catch.
That's the biggest crap I've ever seen.
[silence]
Oh, what?
I'm in the water?
I told you to be careful.
Oh, you can't.
How do I get in the water?
Random bad as old man.
Do we see any canaries around the man?
Are there any canaries?
Like probably 12 of them?
Oh, never mind.
How deep is the water?
What you saw?
Well, he's not it.
Bestie senior.
Can you get that old man?
I got the wrong going that one.
Bestie senior.
[silence]
Like that.
I'm be standing on that scene.
Oh, man.
What the fuck just happened?
[silence]
It's me, Dice.
Why are you here?
And why is the dome smoking?
[silence]
Yes.
No, no, no, no, I gotta.
Hey, hey, I gotta interject.
The clown was a slave.
He was a slave to the thing.
And they mistreated this crab.
Like, this clown has a special bomb with this crab.
You can send him on this way.
Okay, he was a slave.
Well, it's gonna be difficult.
I'm just letting you know right now.
Yes, you're not gonna get any information from him.
He is.
But literally, he only thinks about the crab.
That's it.
I'm gonna be honest.
Well, well, I'm not a thief.
I'm not a thief.
You promised I would be alright.
If you're not.
If you're not, it's fine.
[silence]
Alright then.
Listen, I'm not.
I'm not.
I'm not too late.
No, hope.
I'm not.
But I can't give you, I can't give you the clown.
Or the crab.
What information from him?
[silence]
No, you don't.
I will dim in mercy.
We were planning on to where they were from to sit down.
The operation to not.
Listen to you, Steve.
So adamant about it.
You can do it yourself.
But leave him out of this.
[silence]
You said you weren't dying.
So what is your job?
I won't call you a monster.
[silence]
That's it for critical view.
You really bring to do no evil.
And everything you do is right.
And you're not.
You're talking about justice through kindness.
But we saw an island that you guys were.
You guys get your gear from that are linearly killing people.
You're angry about a group kidnapping people.
Which means you have no position.
Exactly.
Okay, so then I'm talking to her.
You were talking about kindness and la di da la di da.
But we saw an island where Marines get their gear from.
And we saw an island that you guys were literally killing people
and paying for it.
What do you have to say to that?
But yet you want to take this man.
Well, we're good thing we're not.
We ain't thieves or miscreants.
Hey, way first off.
[silence]
Oh, man, you need a stopper or so help me God.
I'm going to have already on the information you need.
You are not taking that.
No, you're not.
And it is a living creature.
You can't just come and dare a living creature of the sea.
What would happen if you were a vessel when you could put a rock above?
We can't hear you.
How did you know you had to cross a con belt?
We haven't said where it is.
[silence]
You're still not taking either one of them.
No, we haven't.
You can just ask him where the thing is and go wherever he goes.
Like, you can just ask him for direction.
You don't have to capture him.
He wants to take Bessie so they cross the belt uninterrupted.
So he can ask.
He doesn't need to take.
Like, he can ask Bessie, if he's willing to take him.
You don't get a force, the guy.
No, I'm not okay with that.
No, she tried to put cuffs on his ass.
That ain't cooperation, that's slavery.
Hey, look, old man.
You seem like a very peaceful and understandable person, right?
And you also don't want to fight.
Am I guessing that's right, right?
[silence]
Thanks for the danger of my life.
But you see, we, I'm going to look at this since they weren't we thinking about taking care of the slave trade thing.
Excuse me, sir.
We are trying to, sir.
Look, we are trying to give you our option.
Okay, we're trying to talk it over, right?
Dude, look, this guy, this guy is older than you.
Don't talk before when elders are speaking.
Do not talk when elders are speaking.
Okay, little girl.
[laughter]
Look, sir.
You see, I know that you guys can be really powerful and you can take care of it out yourself.
And you would love to, but you see, we don't want this big guy and his vessel, whose name is Bessie,
hurt or in any kind of danger. We want to see it through and if you wish we can cooperate and that's the way we're going to.
That's our middle ground, right?
Exactly.
How about we make sure that they don't come into harm and we will be out of your way?
[silence]
Sounds great, but which one is better for you?
Or just ask for a causing problems in your life. Like, choose the peaceful way.
But we promise you you would do safe. We gave you a word that you would be safe.
You go with them. We can't guarantee.
But after you said you had to throw in that last little bit as long as you cooperate. He may not want to do what you guys are doing.
Because we've seen firsthand Marines.
Ask the winner if the girl gives the
person a chance to do something.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. I need some sort of way where I know he'll be all right.
Because I, under good conscience just can't go by your word. I need some sort of verification.
I don't know. You're going to have to figure something out.
Because I've seen the torture you guys allow firsthand. And I don't know if I'm allowed, I'm going to allow you to do that to this main.
And we'll verify ourselves. Because we'll be tagging along.
And I think otherwise we're not so
wrong.
I'm going to roll today.
I'm going to roll.
If you want me to use that bandage, I'm not using it because there's no way I can succeed it.
I'm not using it.
I'm still on it.
I'm going to roll.
So he did that just to talk.
I'll start making my way outside.
Correct.
What about you guys?
I'm going to roll.
I'll show you.
You protected us.
Even though we're not.
Thank you.
I'm going to roll.
Is everyone else awake yet?
I'm not.
Obviously that man may not be in our old man may not be in our realm to handle at the moment.
I'm worried about now.
Do you want to do on like some sort of guarantee that they're going to do it?
I'm worried about that.
It's not a man.
It's a matter of bestie being by himself.
I'm worried about that.
Excuse me.
Hey, Bob.
What's up?
I want you to go around and one up that little girl in fixing everything.
Excuse me.
I really don't want to go anywhere near that little girl.
I'm busy.
Excuse me.
After an hour, I'm checking his HP.
Just keep that in mind.
I'm doing what you're doing.
I'll follow him.
I'm just going to follow him.
I will understand you.
I'll follow him.
Why not?
I'm going to follow him.
I'll follow him.
I'll decide after.
You still want to lay all pirates the same.
Are you not?
The only thing this I'm safe right now is because of us,
pirates.
You, Marines, this is your island.
These are your people.
You abandon them.
They're going to take them in the village.
Do I know a bit?
I'm going to follow him.
I'll follow him.
You will never understand the pain.
He's why I'm alive.
I'll follow him.
I can't disappear.
No one knows where he is.
I'll follow him.
The best I can do right now is follow the mission he left gave me.
Who's horse?
I'll follow him.
I don't know.
I know.
I'll follow him.
I said I'm not abandoning passie.
I have a promise to fulfill.
I'll follow him.
I'll go on board and look around.
Long the island.